hey guys we're back on the Tendo
treehouse live at e3 and we have a
special game for you today I am Eric and
this is Terry hey we have two
representatives from Ubisoft to show you
Mario Plus Rabbids Kingdom battle so
with that let's jump in you guys take it
away
sure so thanks a lot they said please
you have to be here yeah thanks again so
we're super happy today as well because
we're going to show something special
that we didn't show anywhere else so
it's a first as well to reveal that
today so we'll do step by step but yeah
we wanted to give love and the more
content as well and just a sneak peek
into the storyline and even a bus fight
so again more e+ rabbit-skin the metal
is a tactical adventure with rabbits and
Mario and already we see a new character
on the screen here with Luigi as in the
first part of the demo even yesterday
that we saw we're about to unlock VG and
now it's done so yeah so we'll jump a
little bit later into the first world so
still the beginning of the game but we
felt it was a cool spot to show a bit
more advanced elements compared to
yesterday yes so I love one of my
favorite things about this game is how
deep it is
yeah so we're super excited to show ya
those elements and you'll see it's a
nice wrap up like yesterday but this
time with some new elements so yeah so
that's the Jenga tower that we call the
Sun is going down and it's at the end of
the first world and we can talk about a
bit more about the verticality of it
yeah this one was a it's near by the end
of the first world and it's really quite
different compared the rest of the game
because instead of being a developing
horizontally goes up vertically so it's
just a small proof of the mass the twist
in the mushroom kingdom that rabbits
arrival are created
and it's a very interesting level design
because you know very well that in our
game we have weapons that can use
special powers that we call super effect
so you can plug into the weapon the
super effect such as the bounds on the
push
so being these a tower that is almost
about to crumble and goes up into the
clouds it's super easy to use one of
those power and push a bounced enemy out
of boundaries but the fact is even the
enemies can do it on you so you have to
watch out and when players will arrive
at the top of the tower they will see
that there is something strange like hmm
there is a chapter in front of them with
the scroll that is gold and black so
maybe something big is about to begin
so in that cases it's better to be
prepared and what Sofia can do is go
inside the battle HQ and set up is team
select the weapon and f-fun with the
scripture which is going to be
fundamental players can also decide
which kind of ears they can select and
as each 0 as its own ability and skill
its fundamental will say no I don't know
which is your peripheral team Excel yeah
yeah already sorry to selected I really
like Luigi like me too we saw a little
bit of that yesterday but it's health
point is really low at this part of the
game compared to for example rabbit
peach but he's really good from far and
doing for our distance damage so it's a
longer range guy yeah
and we see here for example rabbit Luigi
that we won't choose today for the fight
but started to have the vampire - 30
damage so it's the highest - damage that
heroes have at first with this room but
he also add vampire effect which the
enemy become vampire and then
every time you hit the enemy you get
life even if Mario is shooting him or
Luigi
you're gonna get live such a life pool
which is quite interesting input so he's
really this little guy he's very
strategical because you use it on some
enemy and maybe all your ears can shoot
up into recover part of the major dealt
on the enemy right yeah so you'd want to
you know in your turn when you're in
battle like use him first so you use
that status effect and then your other
heroes could benefit from it absolutely
and then we have the second part of the
preparation like Davide was saying it's
all about the weapons you know we have
200 more than 250 type you know and
different weapons so really when a far
into you know putting different stats
different elements like you know the
bounce effect is my preferred bounce I
mean super effect because it bounces the
enemy away potentially at the
battlefield and you know you have added
damage and it's like in Mario Kart you
know when you get out of the road and so
this approach is just yeah super cool
and if you add that to I don't know you
you burn the enemy and then with your
second character you just bounce the
enemy away and it works on mid boss as
well so it's really like it's awesome to
see on the screen yeah especially if you
have certain enemies that are rushed
type enemies kind of rushing at you yeah
keep that distance is remember yeah
absolutely
and you can use those super effector in
combination with the techniques so you
may use the techniques with Mario which
is called
your site that prepares Mario meaning
that if an enemy will move nearby him he
will shoot even if it's not Easter so
just imagine that you do the same with
other characters and enemies moving
Margot's your site shoot the enemy the
super effect bounce apply the enemy fly
over the battlegrounds enters in the
area of reaction of one of the other
ears that shoot again and maybe applies
the burn effect and as the benefit is
something that the allows for
propagation you will see that if the
enemy touches other where other units
they will start to pack up the
propagator
on here yeah and here we see a secondary
weapon you know yes tonight Rafael
mainly nights it's awesome it's Mario's
hammer and you have a lot of them of
course it's locked so far you have to
unlock them through the adventure but
here it's a good example of a little bit
more advanced element so for example
your first hammer did you get on the
game is good you know the damage output
is good you have a you know you cannot
use it every turn but still even it with
the cooldown it's quite cool but if you
look at the second one here not only it
adds the honey damage and glue the enemy
on the ground for 30% chance which is
incredibly cool if you do it on a
Smasher for example because you can't
move anyway anymore
to attack your other heroes but also
what do we see on the top right is what
we call the good damage against
something and here it's the Ziggy's plus
30 damage chance here to apply what you
have on the Ziggy so that's really cool
because it means if you have a lot of
Ziggy's around by using this weapon can
be very effective so this is something
you need to watch out because every
weapon has something different but it's
not very simple yeah then they start to
we stop throughout the expect eyes right
yes and asks that we said we had these
elements of proficiencies so some Weber
are more efficient against some type of
enemies and some weapons are more
efficient against the cover so a god
rest of the type of code you can damage
those even faster
another example before we go on with the
skill tree that's the the century so
rabid peach can use a second rapid
centuries and a big difference here is
if you look down there
150 life point so it's like a hero new
hero right it goes on okay yeah I'm
there too and it applies to push damage
and push effect which is great it's not
like the balance a bouncies really
balancing it all and puts a chill out of
the zone the push could do the same you
could be push out the the zone itself
but you can also push another enemy
behind so it's like a domino
so it's quite effective here so this
little guy this little century can we go
and really try to to affect the enemy
your target and then just push everyone
around with an AoE type of effect so the
kravid damage is not really high on this
one you know it says low so it's not
going to destroy that much of the covers
but later in the game potentially have
some very good weapons to destroy covers
in one hit which could be a very
interesting for strategy the philosophy
of the weapon that we have in our gaming
can be divided into macro area the
primary weapon that are a very direct
way to deal with the enemy they damage
one single unity and the secondary
weapon that are basically area of damage
once again those weapon the secondary
weapon works pretty well in combination
synergy with some of the techniques that
some of the character the US will have
later on in the game such as the magnet
dance which is the ability to learn all
the enemies around you nearby in an area
and this is where you want to eat with
an area of the major weapon
catcher and ass but at least the skill
tree really important to to do it before
a big fight so I'm going to reset here
because you can reset whenever you want
so basically it's a good way to so you
see the fight seems to be a big fight
you have a lot of covers and stuff you
even have coverage that cannot be
destroyed so when you look at that you
can go back to the battle barrel to you
and adapt your strategy your weapons
like we said but also of course the
skill tree so example with Mario so just
quickly we have moving attack technique
and other other elements that we can add
as well and which are very important
because you can change how much of the
character can move in the area of
movement or the stamina or a much health
will gain back when he will find
mushroom ax in exploration or
after the era of movement outside the
pipe the habit pipe that you can find in
the battleground so for example here I
have 40 orbs so you know those orbs are
what you get from fight if you did very
well in fight you get more orbs so as
soon as they have orbs you can start to
spend them so the very first element
that Mario can do in this moving phase
is that upgrade to what we call the
stump jump
so basically thanks to this you will be
able to do a team jump like before but
then stomp on the head of the enemy for
damage as well and it's another boost as
well in terms of reach and zone of
movement so that's a very cool element
so you just upgrade it mario is happy
and starting now you can do it in fight
right away nice and then it's up to you
to upgrade so you can upgrade your - -
damage and as you proceed into the game
it's going to be more and more expensive
so you'll have to make choices where you
want to put your points so you can have
put your points at the end of the game
over everything you have to choose
drastically where you want to go for
each of them so Mario can be very
different from one player to another one
right it's really letting the player
experimenter with the game it's one of
the key feature that we wanted to have
in the game but also for the player that
doesn't want to they can press the
autofill function and so base if it's
what we decided for the play of the bear
yes
battery the path path that's awesome
yeah I'm sorry so what's great about is
- you like it you can even reset it
every time and so depending on what
battle you're in you just sit to that
current standard so then you're able to
counter for the environment for the
enemy so it's it's great that being that
you can change it every time it's a
great possibility different varieties a
battle that's why we wanted to have
before the fight really have a look into
the the battle feel itself so you can
adapt that's right the difference with
boss fights you don't have this
preparation phase - it's really up to
you to discover what the fight is so you
have to go in a way that you look at the
battlefield and okay I'm going to try to
go for that but you'll be surprised with
the boss because you don't know what's
going to happen that's what
show I guess we'll see what's going to
happen here in a second yeah so I'm
gonna buy the secondary weapon as well
there's no contrast Delta field or we
can trust the other field so this
feature is interesting if you want to go
straight into the action so you press Y
and the game says you wanted me to fill
the the element of course it's based on
what we chose depending on your rank and
where you are but of course it's
something that maybe is not totally
connected to what you would do but you
can have this option as well so let's go
can't wait pretty excited for this now
so they just arrived on top of the tower
here so we can talk a little bit more
about the story so Mario just trying to
guide though yeah and uh Mario Luigi and
rabbit peaches saw this little guy that
we saw that yesterday as well so he's
actually the cutest threat ever he's
responsible for everything and all the
enemies you see in the game why because
he's able to fuse a white rabbit with
something from Mario's world and why
because when he stressed and his stress
level is super high while he's gonna
create those enemies it the more stress
the more the bigger the enemy will be
gotcha so Bowser jr. who observed that
from far during the the first world like
hey I can use this little guy for me and
create my ultimate army and potentially
you know take over in Mushroom Kingdom
finally you know while his father is
potentially on vacation somewhere so
he's calling his Pawnee it's busy
spawning stuff and he's gonna test right
now and even convince this little guy
this lil guy is so naive that you know
things that Mario and his friends were
trying to catch him up to do something
with him so he was super stress so when
he sees Bowser jr. he's convinced that
he's a good guy so yeah I'm gonna join
him and now we're going to see you know
a fusion between two things between the
banana and a rabbit and what it's you
know it brings on the table
I think was a junior set you up love it
so is happening really at the end of the
first world and it's the very first book
boss battle of the game as each word is
divided in chant and chapter like
chapters of the book at the middle of
each word there is a mid-boss fight and
at the end of each board there is a bot
boss fight
so kong is a super jealous of the bunch
of bananas in front of him and so
doesn't want no one to come near by
those banana because he wants to keep it
for for him and the player if here will
have really to understand how to deal
with the boss right so there is a little
bit of oscillation going on here for the
player so we start to see what we saw
yesterday but it did more advance for
example here rabbit peach thanks to the
skill tree that we just saw before she's
able to double dash and has her - damage
is at 20 it's a good damage you know for
starting to hit the enemy so I can press
again and continue my movement and
that's just a movement phase so exact
actually damage the enemy in the
movement phase and then still attack
exactly I could attack right away the
enemy but I'm going to show you the
second character here come with Mario so
we saw of course more you can - you can
do something like team jump just before
so with rabbit beach team stump as I
just shown in the skill tree it's all
about chaining the ability that you are
upgrading in your cactus enjoy being a
master ichiro as its own it's really up
to the player there's so many different
varieties of chaining these attacks and
then I just can press a he goes 20
damage team jump team stomp defeat the
enemy the process and then I'm well
positioned to flank both enemies
actually and here for example this one
with the
the piston panic gun that we have here
so the damage is way over than the
enemy's remaining life so even if I
apply the bounce effect it's just going
to be cool because any way is going to
fit in Rocio
Oh got him there we go and then Luigi
he's starting to be far away but he
doesn't care because you know he's
really good with range look at the rain
she can you know shoot at enemy for the
world bottom go around almost maybe on
the left top laughs you can't but he's
the one like he can shoot anything from
afar that one looks like a Hoover so
seems like a citation I'm going on in
the sniper and just before we see the
Sentry here and we start to see you know
where this entry could go and it says
with the red dot that he won't be able
to reach that enemy in the first round
gotcha but what is cool is that if the
enemy comes nearby by mistake it's going
to explode you know it's going to wait
for the enemy to enter in his zone so I
can try to show this you'll see so it's
really different it's a little new hero
and you see this bubble that's the the
range that as soon as eme enters he's
gonna shoot so let's switch and see if
DME goes rabbit teaches not well
positioned here I wanted to show for its
kind of exposed yeah we didn't protect
him very well
and now the Sentry can go and continue
and do that damage and you see the cover
damage was not great but still it worked
it worked and uh so I'm gonna show you
know the hammer that we bought in the
skill tree as well here with Mario even
if it's not needed as the enemy is
almost done but you see what we saw
there was the zone of attack so anyone
around what I've been shot and as I did
a lot of damage a lot of points can be
taken so that's pretty cool so one thing
I will try with Luigi yeah we can
show rabid Kong in the passo in the
background so this is just the first
phase we won't show the whole thing
because it's a bit longer but the thing
here with him is that even if I can
reach him like I'm going to do here it's
going to do some damage
but not really because every time he
eats a banana is going to get their life
back so of course we know the game we
know what to do but basically here you
need to adapt so so basically the player
needs to find a way to get rid of those
bananas otherwise Congo will keep
replacing else forever got to be
perceptive yeah so let's try to go in
that zone with rabid peach thanks 14
jump roach BAM the bananas just fell
down
so Kong is super than that yeah so now
as he's looking for his bananas and he's
cute it's almost a pity to hurt my
finger - yeah look at that
the disparate animations in this camera
so that's all so I'm gonna try to shoot
damn now we can do damage and apply
which is pretty cool but the issue is
that was maybe a little too close oh oh
my god
he's Superman so you have to watch out
because basically it could be really bad
for you so you need to leave the zone
and start to shoot again so for example
with the revenue G with a big damage
output with Mario and then with rabid
peach it is pissed yeah this is your
time
you gotta get that bang let's go and
boom there we go so this is just the
first phase of the combat itself and
then he's gonna move on into new zones
new types of enemies will start those
wave if you're not behind full covers
you get bounced away so your life starts
to go down out of boundaries etc so and
that's something that uh we won't show
more right that was just my first face
and this is a long boss fight yeah it's
a 30 minute I would say yeah 30 minute
boss fight that's what I'd love to hear
so alright thank you so much for being
here it's awesome to show that it we're
super happy
well I'm Skewes man this game is turning
out so good I'm really impressed so Q
thank you so much for watching next up
we have an exclusive look at Super Mario
Odyssey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]